this is one of the most fascinating
things about being a lawyer
for entrepreneurs or for
ceos or whoever
[Music]
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm well
considering the this ground corona days
and
pleasure to be with you my pleasure to
be with you i mean i'm saying
you know i was about to say good morning
but it's actually your evening soon
even though the sun still seems to shine
you're in you're in israel right now
right
right right and the sun is sitting right
behind me
that's wonderful that's wonderful
leonard it's a it's a privilege to have
you it's an honor to have you
because uh your you know your 25 years
of experience in the legal field and
within shibota and within high tech
you know as a young entrepreneur coming
into this journey even though i do get
exposed to venture capital quite a bit
now
seeing the legal side of things and
understanding the complexity
of things that go into the life cycle of
a startup to m
a's to investments it's something that's
almost like a big black box
to a to a lot of entrepreneurs not just
young entrepreneurs i'm assuming
and what i'd love to do in the in this
in this you know discussion
is dumb it down for me and i want to
explore what are the things that
i can be curious about what are the
things that i maybe shouldn't be curious
about
and what are the biggest pitfalls that i
can avoid as a young entrepreneur
but before that leor just i'd like to
know who you are
and talk to take me a little bit through
your journey of of you know going into
the high tech
already in the early 90s as you
mentioned before it was considered high
tech
right right so i i started uh doing high
before there was an israeli high attack
just because
you know before in 1990
um there were no venture capital in
israel
so uh i i was lucky enough just by
coincidence like
all good things in life or
or lucky enough uh to to be
among the lawyers that started to work
with
vc's early 90s we actually
needed to the the
subject in israel so what we did
is took the books of the nbca
from california and
kind of translated them into hebrew
not in the uh language linguistic
sense but in the legal sense and
it was quite an experience because just
you know to
then negotiate uh and explain to the
other lawyers in israel what what
why and you need preferred chairs and
all those
issues that are just you know you know
that everyone knows that
but then it was like something like a
revolution
you you heard the revolution it's really
literally pioneering a lot of these
and a lot of these you know formal
definitions and communications between
the different parties
and uh and it must have been quite quite
an experience
what made you go into that side of high
tech so as you're getting exposed to
these
to these different things you choose to
concentrate on them you choose to be a
pioneer in this domain why
why do you do that oh that's easy that's
easy to answer you know
israel they pre-hide it
it's like the the covet 19 pre and post
nothing will be the same
yeah much more okay i hope much more
than that
israel pre-i-tech for in the little
sense
in the legal profession was like
something that was
that's not going to change and the
clients
the larger clients were that where they
are at that point
i was a young lawyer there there was no
other field
where you can you know start with this
smallest client ever
like two entrepreneurs and turn into
within two years to have a huge client
you know they're the largest in the firm
and this is exactly what happened there
to a few of our clients so uh for me it
was easy i was young in
enough those days to to adapt to the
change
so we actually it was natural to stay
where
you know it's low-hanging fruits for in
the living profession at that time
which is their fruits nowadays are much
higher
that that i can assure you yeah so now
is there i mean
let's say you're now looking at new
opportunities and let's say you have
new founders i mean i'm looking at
myself i'm starting
as i start a company i don't have the
funds to go and pay a lawyer and pay
a legal firm in the caliber of of
shiboli and i want to have the best
caliber because i truly believe in my
business and i truly believe of where
i'm going and in my fundraising skills
so what adaptations are there for the
tech scene
that might be a little different than
any other industry in terms of
you know partnering with a firm like she
bullet to work together
is it is it the same as other industries
or is it a little bit different
okay so this is uh i i think that we
started with the right
foot uh in this sense uh
the fact that things move very
fast in in the high-tech scene allows us
to basically do things that are unheard
of in other fields
of of the legal industry so
we have programs uh of
fees that are actually uh
arranged for for start for statistics so
if we believe in your startup so we are
actually in most cases the first
investors in your startup
right you're an entrepreneur you come to
the lawyer lawyer in
in many cases is just the first station
that
you park and uh you and
because this is the first advice and it
should be the first advice that you get
uh and uh in order not to avoid from
mistakes later on at that time you are
the most
vulnerable stage in your career
it's easy to make mistakes it's
difficult to recover
because you are too weak at that point
so that's the reason that
we we we are actually equipped
uh to to take over uh all the stuff of
of of those startups that we believe in
so and it's not easy actually so when we
look at the team
it's it's not easy to filter we use our
best senses and we do
lots lots of mistakes because
we are not a better investors than any
other investor and we all
do uh
how is your due diligence compared to
that of venture capitalists
um we are not
into the technology side at all so we
look at the people
we look at their background we hear the
story
uh and we if we need
we take advice from friends that
are more into the technology side
or we look in or we talked we put with
potential investors
and we hear from them and sometimes uh
we we just you know we feel
uh we feel the personality uh you it's
we you need actually to try to locate
the winners
that's the issue it's people at that
point
uh so we have we don't have
uh the all the tools in the world but we
have our experience
and in many cases we you know we we do
it in teams
so i have a partner he's coming to me
look i have this
young startup it's in the area of so and
so and they want to do this and this and
and i'm actually i'm not sure so
sometimes i meet with them
again sometimes we we talk we do a
little bit of due diligence
about the team that's it that's what we
have
we are doing the best with what we have
at that point
okay that's incredible and and what
excites you most in this job is that
is it more the the early stage
entrepreneurs is it the bigger clients
that that you know that they grow to
where where are you on the spectrum
and actually all over
there is a lot of
interest in partner and and i look at
me at us as partners of this
of the entrepreneurs that's what we are
we
we are we we are with them in the
trenches
we feel that the task we are we're there
so with them it's in the beginning you
feel you create something you are a
creator
you bring value other other value than
what they have
which is a lot of experience and so
forth
and they and and they bring their
innocence which is very important for a
southern peace right right
so that's at that stage but you know
what
what's interesting in the tech area
is that no matter maturities there is
the technology company
they always at a struggle for life
they are struggling so and and in many
cases
the lawyer is the only friend true
friend
of the ceo what does that mean because
you know i'm imagining a company that
you know
you know a deal fell through maybe like
a big customer
is not is no longer a paying customer or
you know they're they're
they're seeing uh they're not they're
having a hard time raising their series
errors so
what do you mean that you are the only
friend of the ceo or that you're in
there with the trenches because it's
hard for me to imagine a legal firm
being a friend of the ceo it seems like
it's like it's not a friendship
relationship it's much more of a formal
relationship
okay now well look this is the
difference in
the i i think at least in the way we do
uh lawyering uh
that the there is a is an issue of
chemistry with your lawyer you need to
trust the lawyer
the the advice that the lawyer gives you
and the fact in many cases look uh if a
client
lives and you can't do anything right
you are a lawyer
but the question whether uh
to go and do
haircuts in salaries or
to to do layoffs for example any other
person
in the company has its own interest
right
you are not interested right you are
just
there you are his advisor so this is a
very unique position
and and this is one of the most
fascinating things about being a lawyer
for entrepreneurs or or ceos or
whoever you know like that's the tech in
other industries it's not like that
they are the the pa the pace is very
different
and managements are thicker in many
cases
it's with with technology companies you
know
even the ceo or the most experienced
person
at least in the israeli arena has done
i know three m is in his life right
right right i did 300.
you see so this is this is it it's like
that's
that's a big difference right right so i
greatly enjoy
so first of all it sounds to me that
you're the
another key difference from what you're
explaining than what a vc might
have is in terms of the risk assessment
so the risk that you're taking on as a
firm when you take on two
you know two entrepreneurs or two
engineers from the technion
or or whatever it's it's a different
risk than what a vc might
take when they're making you know
they're one out of six investments so a
vc might make six investments a year
but you're able to you know take 60
clients a year
or perhaps even more and then so you're
able to you're seeing many more deals
and you're obviously
seeing many more success and failure
stories and
and i have to ask then if you're you're
seeing so many of these deals both
both as successes and failures there
must be some patterns that start you
know coming together again
whether it is you know pitfalls in the
early stage
uh pitfalls in the late stage maybe
common successes
or common traits of an entrepreneur that
are among other successful ones but what
have you been
observing in your years
i think that there are endless factors
and that's that's reality and it's very
easy to fail
so there are like a million reasons to
fail
and so and only
if all the stars are aligned that this
is very rare
then you see a big success but
but let's move from early stage early
stage
when you are just the the first team
it should be a coherent team yeah
and and the the team should be in
in most cases very clearly defined there
is a technology guy there is a business
guy
there it is and and they should actually
be
work well together in a sense that
the qualities of one are making for
uh the disadvantages of the other and
and you can
actually you know if you are a little
bit into people
you understand and you see that you see
that
right the conversation flows and and
things work
yep and uh at that point it's very
important to clear each
of the entrepreneurs founders at that
point that they are the founders right
so
uh their role to make sure that they
understand that they set expectations
and and so forth so and it's easy at
that point
to make a mistake you know not not to
define things and work three months
and then three months or six months down
the road
discover actually you are not aligned
like waterfall young and yes and
one and goes away and the other is
staying there
doesn't have the rights to the
technology the other one is fighting for
shares if there will be a company and
then everything is just lost
that's very low do you see a lot of
preemptive conflicts
in regards to shares equity salary
iep is there too much of that
of you know preemptive conflicts that
are just you know stalling and not
letting the entrepreneur continue
too many i'm not sure what is too many
but
i can tell you that yeah i would say
that in
in about 25 the quarter of the cases
that's the issue wow now let's let's add
the next the first stage or the next
stage
is then the investors the identity yeah
they're
easy to make mistakes you will take
on board the wrong the eyes and
all of the sudden when you go to the
next level of
investors you are stuck they are making
troubles they
they do you make your life miserable
do you advise or do you have a do you
provide opinions
on the on the term sheets that the
entrepreneur receives
in terms of the future of the company so
for example if i receive a term sheet
for an investor in a seed that wants
preferred stock and once you know a
board seat and et cetera et cetera
do you sometimes come in and say michael
just be be careful i've seen this thing
before
and it does and i'm not happy with the
way it's gonna go in the next
in the next round yes sure this is this
is basic
i and we are trying first in in the tech
world
and this is the way this is the dna that
actually we try to
uh convey to everyone on the team
uh is uh there is no like
business issue or legal issue everything
is relevant to us
so when i see a term sheet i
give my input to the entrepreneur
assuming that i'm with the advisor of
the entrepreneur
on everything the identity or the way
the investor
uh behaves the uh the way the term sheet
the terms of the term sheet the future
uh the
what is reflected if these are the terms
that are
asked by the investor and so forth yeah
so i i'm trying to
to really be uh as as
meaningful as possible in this sense and
not give
legal comments legal comments you know
every
five years old lawyer can give
yeah so my added value is not there
and we are trying to do even more than
that look we have a team which is
business development for
for clients because we all of a sudden
you know a
a couple of years ago discovered we sit
on
a like a mountain of information
that can assist entrepreneurs and
investors
and in most law firms no one is doing
anything with that
right so we have like a team of three
people that
sit on that data and try and try to
assist so
we we try to give input really deeper
than just
the term sheet even to add with
additional investors and so forth
wow it's one of the 300 it's one of the
300 m
a's it's
this is all this is all incredible
young entrepreneur i'm going to start my
own company soon what are you know what
are
the things that i should be most
concerned about or excited about as i
started my journey how
what is when when is the first touch
point that i need to make with a firm
like shibole
or some other legal firm and what is
there and and
what is the number one thing to keep in
mind because this is you're saying this
is not just
you know i'm not just asking for
shibboleth to incorporate me i'm asking
for a partnership i'm asking for them to
come with me on this journey
and i want them to be in the trenches
with me so i better have good chemistry
with them
right so i think that the right
point is yeah at the first
minute that you have like
usually it's a team right of two or
three people yeah once the
the core team the founders to be the
founders
agree that they have a good idea
that they are kind of determined
to push through together
that is the right time to come to us
okay or to any other lawyer that's very
so so it's as soon as you
as you're agreeing that you're going to
go into this 10-year journey into this
marathon
and you know that you're working
together then this is the right
this is the right touch point okay right
right
wonderful any later you may be
like wasting time or or doing a mistake
that will uh be detrimental later on
so that's it that's the reason that we
are the first
first stop before
i realize that yeah because you know i
as far as i was concerned
today you can incorporate 500 and
delaware online and you can start your
journey and you can start writing your
product and maybe
when you go to that you know and you to
that precede stage and then you need to
quickly you know get a term sheet
then you go and you quickly find the
first legal firm that says hi
to you but you're saying you know this
is actually a long-term investment
this is a partnership with one of the
most important partnerships you're going
to have
in the lifetime of your company and so
so thank you for teaching that
leor right before we leave i want to
thank you again for your generous
generosity with your time
and your your inspiration and you know
the 25 years of experience you bring
with you i think that's incredible and
i've learned so much and i'm sure that
anybody listening has learned so much
but i need three words that you would
use to describe yourself
okay so actually i i will use
i think one word i'm a
multi-disciplinary
and that's with respect to personality
and kind of qualifications or or
talent so i'm i'm that's my i'm i'm a
wrong person
i love it i love it uh
i it's it came out as an american tada
rabban eh
every conversation is changing in
english it's becoming impossible
so i'll i'll do the same my pleasure
there you go all right and hopefully we
get to work together on an adventure
that i
hope to create very soon we are very
happy to
michael take care enjoy
you